hey everyone dear value here and in
today's video we're going to be going
over the horribly sad and honestly
ridiculous life of akaza before he
became an upper ranked demon and one of
muzan's strongest creations but just
before we do get into today's video make
sure you do all hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video as well as it really helps
out with that algorithm and pushes my
stuff to a bunch of new amazing people
but anyway enough of that let's get back
into the one and only story of a kaza
as the headless casa struggles to
regenerate and fuse himself into
something new he feels someone tugging
at him from behind and asking him to
just stop already becoming annoyed he
tells her to let go but the beautiful
young lady tearfully asks him why he
wants to become stronger not realising
his sudden change he turns to her and
tells this figment of his imagination
that it is because he won't be able to
bring it back he won't be able to save
his dad flashing back over two centuries
we find the brutal icarza was actually
kind but a confused young man who went
by the name of hakuji soyama hakuji was
born and raised in these slums to a
sickly father that he deeply loved in
order to pay for medicine and food
soyama pickpocketed from people in town
but was caught three times resulting in
the first of his three tattoos the
magistrate beats him threatening to cut
off his arms the next time he was caught
finally calling him a demon child before
leaving him when hakuju returned home
after his third beating a neighbouring
villager informed him that his father
having heard of his arrest had hung
himself in the final lesser he had left
for his son he stated that he wanted
hakuji to live an honest fulfilled life
and didn't want to be such a burden on
him especially if everything was earned
by dishonest means with his criminal
tattoos and no home to return to hakuji
was eventually banished from ido as a
whole devastated by the loss of his
father and enraged at the society they
lived in where he could not afford his
father's medicine he picked fights with
people and beat them up one day after
nearly killing seven adult men in a
village he was approached by a random
man the owner of a local dojo who'd been
called to actually help the young boy as
everyone had suspected these seven older
men would beat him to death while
looking at the man he starts to realise
that his memories are coming flooding
back in
as they talk hakushi becomes extremely
annoyed by his man's cheerful demeanor
and charges at him challenging him to a
fight but when he goes to hit him he
gets completely and utterly decimated
with ease as he wakes from the beating
hikuchi finds himself under the care of
that man whose name turns out to be
kaizo he was the master of a dojo they
taught the bare-fisted fighting style
sawyu but he didn't have a single
student so he made his way by doing
simple handyman work keizu then took in
soyama so that he could nurse kaiyuki
kaizo's sickly daughter sadly her mother
had drowned herself due to the stress of
raising her dying daughter and kaiser
had to work handyman jobs to keep them
afloat so hikuji was tasked with tending
to her in reality as he thinks he
wonders why do sick people always
apologize why do they think they are a
burden
they should be the one in their most
pain
he says that kiyuki had a really weak
body but because he was already
accustomed to caring for his father he
had little to no trouble looking after
her
though he found it awkward when she
burst into tears seemingly at random one
of those times unbeknownst to him he had
indirectly given her hope by telling her
that there will be a next year to see a
local fireworks show and if they can't
go that year there will always be
another year
kyouki revealed to tsuyama that his
master wasn't a samurai but still
managed to obtain land and a dojo but
when he saved an old man the old man was
so fascinated by a soyu technique that
he handed over the land and the dojo
since he had no successes once a nearby
dojo found out about this though kiyuki
was forced outside and left there by the
air of the neighbouring kinjutsu dojo
that sought keizo's land for themselves
they also prevented him from getting any
students before hakuji was rescued
enraged kaizo and hikuji fought the
other dojo and defeated nine people
hikuji made them promise to never get
involved with the suriyu dojo or kiyuki
again but the ear of the rival dojo
became so enraged that he swung a real
sword at hikogi only for him to use his
belt splitter technique and punch the
side of the blade completely shattering
it the other members of the dojo were so
moved by the beauty of his technique
that they accepted their loss and
apologized for the rudeness of the ear
leaving the suryu dojo in peace
two years later kyuki's health improved
enough that she could stand and do
chores hakugi continued training as
keizo's pupil of the suryou style and
the dojo began to grow one day keizer
offered to let hikuji take over the dojo
and take kyuki as his bride to herkuji's
surprise and embarrassment he agreed
silently vowing to protect them both
even at the cost of his own life at a
festival kyuki told him of her past
asking him if he was really okay with
the proposal to which he reaffirms his
vows to her promising to protect her for
the rest of his life the heir of the
rival dojo though heard about hakuji's
marriage to kyoki so he gathered some
angered disciples and hatched a plan to
seek revenge on the dojo in another
extremely tragic moment hikuchi went to
visit his father's grave to inform him
of his marriage but even while he was
there he realized something was amiss
and upon his return a fellow student
from the dojo informed him that the
rival heir had poisoned the well where
kyuki and kaizo drank water from because
he knew that he would never be able to
beat hakuji or kaizo in a direct fight
sadly the two died almost immediately
after drinking the water sending the 18
year old hikuji into a spiral of
absolute despair enraged at the deaths
of his loved ones hikuji killed all 67
members of the rivalling dojo with his
bare hands crushing their skulls and
destroying their limbs to where their
corpses were no longer recognizable this
specific event was so outlandish that it
became regarded as a completely
fictitious story after 30 years in the
future as he walks through the streets
blooded and bruised a mysterious
cat-eyed figure is seen walking over a
bridge as he approaches the young man
hikuji tells him to move out of the way
or he's dead but as he goes to strike at
him he gets completely and utterly
outclassed suddenly getting stabbed
through the head by the other man's
first the younger muzan begins pulsating
his blood into herkuji's skull while
stating that he was thinking about
creating 12 strong demons he asks him if
he can withstand the amount of blood
that he is about to give him with
nothing left to protect and having lost
his will to live hikugi replies that he
just doesn't care anymore accepting his
fate and becoming their demon a kaza
as his body begins to fade he realizes
that he became a demon and had lost his
memories so he yearned for that strength
once more even though there wasn't
anything left that he wanted to protect
in reality he didn't even want to live
in a world where he lost his family but
for over at least 100 years now he had
kept pointlessly murdering over and over
again yet at the end of the day his life
was just a pathetic comical
uninteresting story
[Music]
well that officially sums up akaze's
life as a human and honestly i can
pretty much say i would have absolutely
hated to have his life as a human if i
was in the demon slayer world as i think
his
life in general has probably been one of
the most heartbreaking stories that i've
had to read and and manga so far like
i'm still quite new to manga and i'm
still you know enjoying getting into it
in general and reading the car's story
here you know finding out about his past
was honestly heartbreaking so
heartbreaking that i had to stop you
know reading through the demon slayer
story at around like chapter 158 and
just jump straight into making this
video here like honestly akaza
is an amazing demon and i really hope
they give him justice throughout the
anime which i'm i'm absolutely sure they
will like seeing him in the moog and
train movie was absolutely cool so i
can't wait to see what they do later on
with him throughout the story especially
in the infinity castle arc which uh if
you guys are interested that video will
be coming out probably towards the end
of next week so about a week from now a
week and a half from now as that is like
60 chapters i've got to cover and
compile down so it is a massive video i
will be doing but that will be coming
out yeah as i just said probably towards
the end of next week so you know keep
your eyes out for that and uh if it does
come out any sooner it will be on my
patreon so make sure you do go over
there and check that out if you want to
get earlier access to these kind of like
explained or larger explained videos
that i do but yeah obviously if you have
enjoyed the video do make sure you hit
that subscribe button and also be sure
to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with that algorithm and
pushes my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people plus you know i can't
really thank you enough for all the
support on the demon slayer content
recently it has been absolutely amazing
and it it just makes it all the more
enjoyable honestly talking about the
series as well so thank you but anyway
for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i will see you
all in a bit bye
[Music]
you